I hate intros haikyuu season 3 we kick
things off the morning of the finals
where he knots his friends from his
middle school volleyball team Azumi and
cozy show up to watch but it's not just
them daichi's why futsuka shame his
brother the players from the
neighborhood team and a handful of
students show up making cata suno's
first cheering squad male let's meet the
shitty Tories our squad as they make
their entrance we have the obvious ace
and biggest threat Wacha Toshi Ashima 8
the semi prey on Akira Satori Tendo
Satoko cheeky kenji yoshida boo Taichi
kawanishi hi-yah to Yamagata and finally
their coach tangi washi jo I just want
to take a minute to point out how truly
thick his eyebrows are those things are
majestic we also learned that the finals
will be a best of five instead of a best
of three like the players are used to
things get started and in the first
player shushila scores with the spite
that went straight to nishinoya getting
on the board
episode 2 things aren't looking so hot
with goddess uno getting smacked around
and falling behind by five points look
Coolio do nosegay turns things around
scoring the first point for cata soon oh
they are really struggling against Ujima
because not only is he a powerhouse but
he's left-handed which they're just not
used to aliens after falling into a
massive deficit Nisha Noah finally
starts to get the hang of his receives
Tsushima seems more competitive than
usual from what Hinata said and goes on
to score the final point in the first
set making it 1-0 in favor of Sheeta
toward Izawa in the second set we see
that Oshima isn't the only threat they
need to worry about as Tendo steps in
and shuts down he not as free quick
episode 3 Tendo analyzes the players and
predicts the place ahead of time which
is how he keeps blocking Hinata this
isn't a perfect straton or an unbeatable
strat though because it's still just an
educated guess
on the other side of the netsuke Shima
is able to make some plays but he can't
find a way to stop Oshima both teams get
tied at 20 so Kai sends in Yamaguchi as
the pinch server which Ujima shuts down
immediately
in the last scene karasuno finally
demonstrate what they had been
theorizing for the match as nishinoya
blocks
Ashima spiked with the help of suka
Shima's timing on the block yep so for
the game goes on until the teams get
tied at 24 while continuing to fight for
momentum the quick attacks are as
devastating as ever and mission OA is
consistently receiving Ujima spikes we
see that the tipping point however comes
from suka Shima as for the first time he
blocks through Shima and scores the last
point winning the second set making the
score 1 to 1 II episode 5 we don't watch
the third set in too much detail but she
did Tony Sawa end up winning 25 to 20 as
we get into the fourth set it's clear
that both teams are getting used to each
other's rhythms Tsushima isn't scoring
as much while kata soon who synchronizes
attack gets blocked for the first time
Hinata is able to make his first block
after using a running start to gain a
little bit more height in his jump this
style has some obvious drawbacks as he
runs into the net the next time that he
tries it and not to mention the effect
that it's gonna have on his stamina
episode 6 this score gets tied at 21 in
the fourth set so Yamaguchi is brought
in partly for his serve and also so that
he not I can get some rest
Yamaguchi targets Ashima side to prevent
him from getting the chance to spike and
this sets up sakushima to score this
second serve doesn't go as well and
again OSHA Shima steps in to put an end
to any more possible search from
Yamaguchi again we come into another
dues when the scores get tied at 24
whose shenoy starts to pop off again
stopping Russia Shima serve and keeping
them in the game Hinata is the one to
finish the set out making the score 29
to 27 in favor of kata suno bringing
them into the fifth and final set II
episode 7 it's obvious that the players
aren't used to best of fives and the
length is starting to wear on their
stamina Caggiano is exhausted so
sugawara is put in as the starter for
the last set the last set in a
best-of-five is only to 15 points so
both sides need to be on top of their
game
suger wada proves why he is known for
his consistency but also shows he can
learn new tricks as he scores off of a
spike thanks to his practice Russia
Shima isn't rolling over though and
continues to be the core of the team
with his ability to score
than the lead su Kashima is playing
consistently well and getting blocks up
until he ends up getting injured putting
a huge hole in their defense yep so Dee
it's 8 to 5 in favor of Shiva Tony's
alwa and Su Kashima is out getting his
injury treated so it's up to the others
to hold it together until he gets back
Kageyama is finally put back in and
immediately the duo close the gap
bringing the score to 9 to 8 this
doesn't last long as cheetah toward Esau
is pinched server along with some
playmakers bring the score deficit back
up to 12 to 9 hinata makes a huge play
blocking Ashima spike and scores off of
it this marks the comeback for COD Asuna
as they even the score out at 14 taking
them into yet another deuce they have a
hard-fought rally but cheetah Torres
Alba comes out on top bringing them to
match point everyone's mood seems to
drop drastically after that but just for
a moment because Sioux Kashima finally
gets back from dealing with his cut
episode 9 goddesu no even out the score
and get Sioux Kashima back into play
with him back the defense is in full
swing and who she Jima botches one of
his spikes allowing a counter-attack to
score bringing cada sooner to match
point at 16 to 15 it doesn't end there
though as both teams are in it for the
long haul and keep scoring back and
forth bringing the score to 1919 Mission
Oya comes through big and puts them back
on game point after a superhuman save
while covering for Daiichi episode 10
everyone has their time to shine in the
epic last rally where they are finally
able to overcome chief authorities that
was genius ace surprise surprise Hinata
is the one to score the winning point
after adjusting his timing during a
synchronized attack
[Music]
[Applause]
in the last scene we learned from Takata
that Kageyama was given an offer to
attend the National Youth training camp
we don't know if he accepts or what
happens with that but keep that in mind
going into the next season speaking of
new seasons I'll be doing the next
season and that'll be in the bottom left
whenever I'm finish with it or you can
check out all the high Q recaps in this
playlist here you can also find the
links in the description below and the
only thing I hate more than intros is
outros